[Music]
the a beginner come in the city of
mccurdy is one of dozens dotting the
expansive Benue State in central Nigeria
its inhabitants are just a fraction of
the 171,000 displays that cross the
state by the ongoing violence between
tribes in this part of Nigeria while the
camp was supposed to be a refuge for the
people most don't feel safe here anymore
a sharp increase in rape of women and
young girls is deeply rewarding this
community I fear for my daughters
there are those who send their kids to
go work in the city but not me the
current situation is too dangerous
people here complained that rape has
become so widespread that women can no
longer live the company company Amnesty
International in a recent report
detailed how girls as young as 9 and 10
years were being raped at times by the
very security personnel charged with
protecting them news that a 10 year old
displaced rape victim has delivered in
anyway a few days ago has sent
shockwaves across Nigeria we met the
girl and her baby girl at one of
mokuba's hospitals doctor adikam Michael
helped with the delivery after three
days of labor we need to do a cesarean
section because there was no way Lyubov
enough of waste water so we couldn't
cost much to be caught some units of
blood and we went immediately the baby
these social worker was one of those who
brought the girl to hospital and told us
that she grew up and often and was
raised by her grandmother but was forced
to flee her home when her grandma ran
and called tried to force her to marry a
blind man that is when she fell prey to
the man who raped her despite what she's
been through
the young mother already has dreams for
her baby I don't want my daughter to go
through the same suffering as I did when
she starts walking both of us will go to
school police say they have arrested the
man suspected in her rape last December
but they have this plea for families of
rape victims
punishments for offenders can serve as
deterrents to orders intending to do the
same but one family members tend to
negotiate to kind of receive monies from
from suspects or to try to prevent
prosecution but we family members can
come up to helpers let's the prosecution
process we concluded the plight of the
little girl prematurely propelled to
motherhood is first becoming a rallying
cry for those seeking action on rape in
Nigeria's displaced people's comes many
hope that her case will spar the
authorities to take action to end such
horrendous crime once and for all
Muhammad adieu al Jazeera macabre
Nigeria